I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your Sadaqah Jariyah list.
We're on a mission to teach tens of
thousands of people around the world how
to pray salah properly. Just imagine
this. You help someone learn wudu, how
to pray, how to recite Surah Al-Fatiha,
every Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib, Isha,
Tahajjud, Tarawih. Every prayer for the
rest of their lives, you share in the
reward. [music] When they teach their
children, and their children's children,
the reward continues for you. For just
£100, you can help teach 20 to 60 people
like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
Fantastic. Who's calling? You know it's
this? Allahu Akbar. 1,000.
2,000.
>> Come on. 3,000.
>> We're £323 away. 4,000.
Somebody is at the door. Come on, guys.
Come on. Bismillah. Bismillah.
Come on, guys. £323 away. SMASH IT.
FANTASTIC.
>> [screaming]
[screaming]
>> WE ARE TEACHING PEOPLE HOW TO PRAY. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children, and their children's
[screaming]
children,
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, Tarawih, [music]
Tahajjud. Every recitation, you share in
the reward. For just £100, you can help
teach 20 to 60 people like me learn how
to pray salah. Donate today. Donate
today. Donate today.